skillshare skillshare skillshare
skillshare collect skillsharehold
YouTubers sold out
[Music]
basically every infotainment video on
YouTube pitches skillshare as some sort
of Godly resource do you want to learn
how to code it skillshare do you want to
learn how to animate skillshare do you
want to just learn how to learn
skillshare at this point skillshare
isn't even seen as a learning platform
it's seen as the thing productive people
do clearly skillshare has done a
phenomenal job when it comes to branding
marketing and positioning but the same
cannot be said about the platform itself
skillshare is not only a mediocre
platform it's a negative platform and
that's not my opinion that's the
overwhelming opinion of everyone who
ended up using the platform on
trustpilot for example skillshare has a
horrendous average rating of 1.7 stars
with 32 percent of reviews being one
star ratings and that's despite a
massive upward skew from YouTubers for
example let's say I'm watching Ali abdal
who is an exceptional YouTuber and I
hear him pitch his skillshare course if
I go check out his skillshare course
I'll probably get exactly what I'm
looking for which may lead to a glowing
5 star review but this isn't really a
testament as to how good skillshare is
as a platform and it's really just a
review of an ollie Abdullah or Nathaniel
Drew or Marcus Brownlee if it weren't
for these select YouTubers skillshare's
average rating would probably be closer
to that of PayPal why are people so
upset in the first place well aside from
a history of slimy sales practices
skillshare simply doesn't offer the
value that YouTubers say it does at the
end of the day it's really just a worse
version of YouTube that costs 32 dollars
per month or 168 dollars per year
instead of getting the monthly
subscription you can get a YouTube
premium family plan for six people and
have nine dollars per month to spare or
you you could get a premium Netflix
subscription for four people and it
still have it 12 per month to spare so
here's the truth about skillshare and
why it doesn't live up to all the social
media hype
likely the biggest complaint about
skillshare is that it's not actually
better than YouTube at best it's able to
match YouTube and this is true for
basically any topic that you want to
learn about take Swift coding for
example if you're not familiar with
swift it's the coding language that you
have to use for Native iOS development
so it's a pretty relevant skill yet if
you search up Swift on skillshare you
don't get much more than 50 results and
out of these results only three of them
are actual courses on Swift that last 30
plus hours most of the results are just
introduction or future videos and the
remaining results well they often don't
even have anything to do with swift we
have a video about the principles of
remote work a video about organizing
your life a video about captivation
marketing and a video about Adobe
Illustrator in fact 26 out of the 54
results didn't have anything to do about
Swift or iOS development at all but at
least there's three good courses right
those alone should be worth a
subscription well that's what you might
think until you take a look at what
YouTube has to offer code with Chris
alone has 536 videos all about iOS
development and many of these are over
three hours long and his videos don't
just teach you how to write a function
or class either they teach you how to
make a feature completely functional
from beginning to end how to make a
custom login page using Google
authentication how to link up your IOS
app to a cloud database how to make API
requests to implement external
functionality into your apps code with
Chris's Channel literally has more
content about Swift than the entirety of
skillshare and it is just one channel
there's dozens more like iOS Academy iOS
Academy has a total of 703 videos
covering everything that Chris covers
but he takes it even one step further he
has these massive Series where he builds
full-on Abs from beginning to end for
example he's currently making a Rick and
Morty app completely from scratch that
has a total of 45 Parts this series
alone has over 10 hours of content we
also have Sean Allen Paul Hudson codepro
barbelloper let's build that app and so
many more in just the little niche of
Swift the same argument can be made for
learning JavaScript or animation or
Motion Graphics or cooking or basically
any skill you can think of but none of
this is really surprising YouTube is the
biggest video hosting platform in the
world on skillshare there's a total of
30 000 courses on YouTube there's 30 000
hours of content being uploaded every
single hour so naturally YouTube will
have the most in-depth most
comprehensive videos are on any Niche
and ironically this is true for even the
YouTubers that pitch skillshare all you
have doll for example has a total of
maybe 30 hours of content on skillshare
meanwhile on YouTube he has hundreds of
hours worth of content we should also
note that skillshare doesn't have any
sort of vetting process in terms of who
can post content so basically anyone can
post content on skillshare just like on
YouTube meaning that the content on
skillshare isn't necessarily more
credible valuable or informative
meanwhile there's plenty of
extraordinarily talented teachers on
YouTube itself most of the coding
channels for example are run by former
or even current Fang software Engineers
so even if we take the cost of
skillshare out of the equation you're
still better off using YouTube Not only
does skillshare lack any sort of
distinguishing Factor but YouTube just
totally skillshare in terms of the
amount and the depth of content
thank you
given scale shares a glowing reputation
on YouTube you would think that there
were experts at public relations and
branding and in terms of customer
acquisition they are but if we take a
look at customer experience it's a whole
other story honestly this is pretty
surprising though I don't think that
skillshare is worth the money I would
have expected skillshare to be on the
top of their game when it comes to
customer satisfaction but reading
through these trust pilot reviews that
doesn't seem to be the case you know how
YouTubers always pitch skillshare as
this risk-free service you can just try
it for 30 days and cancel with no
strings attached this idea is plastered
all over their website as well but in
reality the trial process isn't what it
seems these Stevens for example claims
that he was charged for a one-year
subscription after just two weeks of
trial at first skillshare didn't even
reply to any of his messages but even
when they did reply all they had to say
was you have 14 days to cancel from the
day you sign up this likely seems
confusing at first glance but when you
redefine print it all makes sense
basically you do indeed get one month
for free but you get charged for the
following 12 month period before the 12
month even ends this is of course stated
in the fine print cancel before the
trial ends to avoid being charged but if
we're being honest this is rather
misleading the average user probably
hears about skillshare as this Godly
learning platform on YouTube that they
can try for one month completely for
free then they come to this page and
they see all this advertising about this
one free month so they decide to give it
a shot only to be charged 168 dollars
two weeks later and this doesn't seem to
be an honest marketing mistake either
given the number of complaints on
trustpilot itself I'm sure their help
center has been overloaded with confused
customers yeah yet they stick to the
same slimy sales tactic worse it doesn't
seem like they tried to even make it up
to customers Sam for example missed the
refund window for an annual subscription
by just four days and he was refused any
sort of refund at all even if you do get
a refund though you're not out of the
woods just yet because you could be
charged one year later take Roberta's
daughter for example one year ago she
signed up for a free trial she too was
surprised when she was suddenly charged
an annual subscription fortunately
though she was able to contact customer
support and get a refund and cancel her
membership but one year later she was
charged for a renewal when she contacted
customer support again they told her
that they can't issue a refund because
they have a one refund policy which she
had already cashed in on they even sent
her a quote from her original email
thread showing that they had issued a
refund the funny part was that this
quote also contained the evidence that
she had asked them to cancel one year
ago but when this was pointed out to
them they simply stopped replying all of
this is truly quite a shame for a
company that's so good at customer
acquisition but this is simply the harsh
reality of skillshare if all of that
wasn't already bad enough well it gets
even worse
foreign
not only has subpar content that costs a
fortune but they're also preying on
YouTubers most loyal audience when it
comes to skillshare I bet that a
significant portion of people who sign
up aren't even trying to learn they
simply want to support a Creator and see
more content from said Creator similar
to something like patreon but unlike
patreon most of the subscription feed
doesn't even end up going to the
creators patreon only keeps 5 to 12 of
their fees skillshare on the other hand
that keeps wait for it 70 this is
completely unacceptable when you
consider that YouTube itself only takes
45 percent and their content is
available to end users for free
meanwhile skillshare is charging their
users 168 dollars per year which is
again even more than YouTube premium yet
they're only sharing 30 of it with the
actual creators take teachable for
example these guys have become the go-to
place for hosting courses and guess what
they have a free plan for creators that
supports unlimited students this does
come along with the personal fee of 10
but creators can get this personal view
down to Zero by upgrading tiers even
Netflix with people seem to hate is
extremely generous with their revenue
sharing much of the main stranger things
cast for example was paid a quarter
million per episode if all of these
other businesses are able to stay afloat
without taking anywhere close to 70 of
the revenue there's no reason for
skillshare to be taking 70 it appears to
me that skillshare figured out that many
YouTubers have extremely loyal audiences
that are willing to pay up large amounts
of money to get more content and
theoretically support their favorite
creators instead of creating a smooth
platform to enable such support though
skillshare has decided to cash in it for
themselves
foreign
YouTube is filled with the glowing
endorsements of skillshare but much of
this is just due to skillshare Smart
positioning and Brandon behind the
scenes skillshare doesn't accomplish
anything notably great in fact they have
multiple notable negative attributes
they have pretty shady free trial
renewal and cancellation policies and
they only share 30 of their revenue with
creators but even putting those
attributes aside the bottom line is that
skillshare just isn't worth it you're
basically getting a discounted version
of YouTube that you have to pay
exorbitant fees for if any other company
was offering the same service they would
have gotten shredded by the community
but because skillshare is such a big
player within the sponsorship scene no
YouTuber wants to speak out against them
and audiences are led to believe that
skillshare truly is some sort of
exceptional service that's worth the
premium price when in reality that's
just not the case is but that's just
what I think have you ever used
skillshare comment that down below also
drop a like if you appreciate the honest
take on skillshare and of course
consider checking out our Discord
Community such as free ideas and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one
[Music]